so there there's a legitimate argument
against term limits and here it is
is that if let's say i had term limits
of six years or eight years which they
do in california
people show up and they're not even able
to organize into coalitions they don't
really know what's going on and then the
lobbyists just freaking run rings around
them just like you guys don't don't know
the institutions go around the elected
officials right it's the consultants
that stick around and leech or whatever
yes yeah and and there's so much churn
that you can't actually build like the
the proper degree and people probably
just run in for their next office too if
you if you have to be out in a certain
time
yeah it's a little bit too short term
yeah so that so there's a very
legitimate counter argument to this it's
one reason why i'm proposing 18 years
per house because that's six house terms
three senate terms enough time for you
to actually build a degree
of organization uh and hierarchy
and also if you served in both houses
you could have a very full 36-year
career you do for all being a
representative so so that strikes me as
like the right balance
um so there the legitimate counter
argument is like look you can't make it
too short and i was like yeah okay i get
i get it
um 18 years is a pretty long time and
when people the other thing they talk
about is like the learning curve and i'm
just like
what learning curve takes more than 18
years
you know
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back in the studio
zack and andrew
tearing it up forward style tearing it
up i am back from the road for a hot
minute uh but i'm back on the road late
this week by the time this comes out
i'll be doing bill maher on friday so
we're doing a west coast swing which
should be a lot of fun i gotta say
meeting people on the road has been a
blast the people who follow this podcast
and the people who show up to book
events obviously are a lot of the same
people and so there's just been a lot of
love a lot of warmth a lot of affection
i have a lot of truth a lot of reason
a lot of optimism and can do and people
who are willing to envision a different
future it's been positively
delightful the crowds look pretty good
did you get a little nostalgic being
back on the back on the road a bit i did
i saw a lot of people i saw a lot of
familiar faces like the chicago event
for example there are a lot of people
who are like hey i was in iowa i was at
yangapalooza because you know chicago
and i weren't that far apart right um so
there were some familiar faces some new
people
it was like revisiting the presidential
campaign in many respects and then when
i talked about the book i talk about the
presidential campaign a fair amount
because the first third of the book is
just a retrospective on the presidential
campaign and for people who've enjoyed
that part of the book
our friend zach grauman here has a book
coming out about the presidential
campaign where 100 percent of the book
is about the presidential campaign
whereas in my case it's all the stories
you know it's uh i you know i wouldn't
say the bulk of my book is about the
campaign but zach's is and zach had a
better perspective on the campaign than
i did honestly i was like the guy behind
the guy if you will right i got to see
everything you did but from a
non-andrew yang perspective that makes
sense so
um well glad that the trips are going
well you're uh well
we're on the road we're in la next week
we're doing a lot here in iowa you've
got a bunch we'll have the dates at the
end of this podcast today
we got a bunch to talk about
um and but i wanted i think you wanted
to start with which i'm open to there
was some crazy news about china today
that blew my mind and we need to talk
about it i think
oh so this is something i want to talk
about because one of the
big points i'm trying to hit when we're
doing these talks at this point
everything is on the table like whatever
nightmarish dystopian scenario you can
imagine it's now a realistic possibility
in the united states of america yeah and
tensions with china been running high
and it was just announced that
apparently china tested a hypersonic
missile
earlier this year
and it didn't hit its target but it
still came pretty close
and this was a
massive deal for people in the us
because they looked at and said oh wow
we didn't know they could do that yet
and this is something that i just heard
randomly i hear random things at
different points but apparently there's
an engineer at a company that makes
drone components here in the us
who just got a directive you know let's
call it like a couple weeks ago from the
us government to ramp up their
production something
like 100x where all of a sudden the us
thinks it's going to need a whole lot
more drones
and think about what that might mean
like why would the united states be
ordering tons and tons of drones or at
least instructing manufacturers to have
the capacity to develop a component
at scale
that's integral to drones
i don't um well it can't be something
that's passive it's probably something
violent um but i don't know why well
what it made me think is wow the u.s is
starting the game plan as if
it's going to have
more need for
uh
for military drones and that that
probably means a foreign theater uh and
the one that came to mind for me was
china
so what this meant for me is that
whatever nightmare scenarios that i have
been imagining i will confess to you all
most of them have been domestic because
there's no shortage of domestic
nightmare scenarios
uh
you can see
know our climate degrading you can see
our environment degrading our certainly
our political discourses infrastructure
ai healthcare you know
yeah but now we can add into the mix
geopolitical tensions possible ramping
up of a cold war or worse uh between the
u.s and china
afghanistan
wasn't great um i think we talked a
little bit on this podcast um
but this is
clearly different a different beast um
for those of you for those of us who
don't know let's call it idiots like me
what do you know what hypersonic means
when they're in the sense that in the
way they're using it right now does that
mean it breaks a sound barrier um
is yes i think i saw something that said
they go five times the speed of sound or
something along those lines and they
they go at a different
uh
altitude where they go lower
than the conventional icbms which are
the inner continental ballistic missiles
where those essentially you know go way
high and like suddenly leave orbit more
or less
these hypersonic
ones are sub-orbital where they go high
but they don't go as high got it and
that makes them harder to
for example knock down or keep track of
so i read at your recommendation kaifu
lee's book not his newest one i read ai
superpowers and
one of the things they talked about was
china was able to prepare a national
response to
in their eyes climate change if they're
not doing that but to ai in particular
was that books about
while in the u.s like we're still
fighting over whether or not climate
change is exists or not and we're still
fighting over whether coronavirus is bad
for you and whether you should wear mask
or whatever you good on the list um
like even if we don't
or even if we do get our [ __ ] together
if you will as a country is china's just
models set up better to navigate a world
that's like called a post facebook
online world um opposed social media
24-hour news cycle where are they just
better set up
to
lead
in this new world like what are your
thoughts on china's positioning relative
to us
well kaifu lee makes the argument that
china
has more access to more data which makes
sense
uh and
also their citizens are more comfortable
sharing data and
having it be incorporated into their
daily lives
there is
essentially a cash-free society in a lot
of china now where if you were to bust
out paper bills they'd look at you like
you sprouted a second head
so that means more and more data
obviously because you you're tracking
all these transactions
the chinese model one of the the most
unfortunate things that's happened over
the last several years in my opinion has
been the forking of the technology road
where china was using a lot of western
software um
android google base in particular
and that was one of the things that
would help keep the world together
keep us from going to war
and then
for a couple of reasons china
essentially said screw it we have to
develop all of our own technology
platforms we can't be dependent upon u.s
companies part of that was that the us
under trump started saying hey like we
we really don't want to be
working with china in these ways we
don't trust china and when china was
manufacturing
uh network equipment that we're going to
use here in the u.s the trump
administration said no no no right trump
was also examining tiktok which is
essentially a chinese-owned company and
that one's interesting because
a lot of young people in america use
take talk and it's delightful and
everything else i have a tick tock
account check it out official andrew
yang
you haven't you are on time on tick tock
until you found your favorite
political figure slash
but there's a lot of data in tik tok you
know a lot of young people
and
someone having access to all of that uh
is maybe problematic if that someone is
a foreign government in the in the case
of china so china essentially said look
we have to develop our own stuff we have
to not be relying upon the us and this
to me is
a disaster
over time because you're developing
essentially two parallel technology
universes but because they have their
own technology universe and china has
much more autocratic control you can see
them
making various leaps ahead of us because
there are some advantages to it the
counter argument is that most of the
true innovation
comes from u.s companies and
universities and the trillion dollar
question is whether there's going to be
another leap frog in terms of the way ai
gets developed from machine learning to
something else
uh i'm somewhat dubious i think at this
point if you have more data you're
probably going to be advantaged we're
seeing the limitations of the western
model in ai we're seeing in other ways
too
and i just saw a report today saying
that a republican member of congress
mike gallagher on the
house armed services committee said that
china's going to beat us in a cold war
yeah um because their their model
has advantages when you're just looking
at national competitiveness they can
appropriate whatever resources they can
tell companies what to do whereas here
in the us it's a different relationship
so actually i think most people
listening this
probably won't i want your thoughts on
this imagine must agree with this
i've heard that a lot
in various that statement in various
capacities china's kicking our ass
it's been a running joke in number of
ways um
whether it's like pop culture and things
like that but
never talk about what that means when it
pans out
let's say china does
quote-unquote beat us or start operating
more effectively than us becomes the new
superpower becomes a new america like
what does that look like i don't i don't
think it's in either of our country's
interest to go to like an all-out war
right i think you're
more likely just we just have to bend
over their whims at certain slowly but
surely in certain areas whether it's
economic probably economic generally but
it'd probably stem from there like what
is in your opinion i know it's probably
it's definitely speculation what does
this look like
if china starts winning what does that
mean
well the the
major question is would the u.s accept a
china that was quote-unquote winning
and the u.s has had primacy and
dominance in the world for so long that
a lot of its policies are built around
maintaining that dominance right i think
the single most important element of
that to a lot of folks would be the
dollar standard that china's been trying
to
make the room be competitive it has not
worked really right
but
i do i think the u.s would go to great
great lengths including
uh aggressive actions to maintain the
dollar standard yes
and so if china starts winning on a
scale that you're describing
i think a lot of the temptation a lot of
the forces
in
american leadership would drive us
towards increased tension and then
conflict and then some sort of open
conflict the problem
is obviously it's
catastrophic for everyone if the us and
china go to full-fledged
war
the catalyst for this is probably going
to be taiwan
which i have deep relationships with my
my dad's there right now my cousins are
there
and
everything is indicating that china
is
trying to reintegrate taiwan at some
point i mean that's been their about
policy for you know decades and decades
but it seems like that's going to be the
logical flash point because
the u.s has
uh
the equivalent of a mutual defense
treaty with taiwan the last time
china started encroaching the us sent
aircraft carriers and the rest of it uh
it's an open question what the u.s
response would be
it does seem like there are a lot of
elements of u.s leadership though that
are kind of looking for a reason to
confront china while they think that the
conflict if it has to happen is more
winnable
[Music]
[Music]
now more than ever we could all use
someone to talk to someone who gives us
a bit of a pick-me-up
and a lot of people don't really have
that in their lives honestly i don't
know who the heck i would call but you
know what i would do is i would go to
better help and actually get a licensed
therapist who essentially becomes my
on-call
uber
for mental health resource they're
awesome they know what they're doing
they'll actually
be there for you really whenever you
want it really is like magic i genuinely
love better health sponsoring the
podcast because i know they're actually
going to help people there are folks who
are very close to me who are using
better help and you should too
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang over 1 million people have already
taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhealthhelp.com
[Music]
the taiwan
situation is my opinion but curious your
thoughts it's something i think you
could see
probably focus on the left but you could
see like a social justice movement in
the united states like getting ignited
around that as like maybe less so than
you would see like infringement on the
value of the us dollar or other kind of
geopolitical foreign policy topics is
that what you're talking about where we
start like you start getting public
pressure
from
voters in the united states on our
position on taiwan or well what's
interesting is i i think that
standing up to china would be something
that voters on both
sides of the aisle would probably get
behind
uh now
i laugh i'm laughing because i i would
have said the same thing about vaccines
uh well on this one what's interesting
is republicans have historically been
more
enthusiastic about standing up to china
when it comes to encroaching on a
democracy like taiwan and taiwan is a
democracy
so
it's
it it i imagine and this is something
that i feel you know very deeply and
strongly about that i imagine that's
going to play out in our lifetimes in
some form
and it's one of the most important
questions or challenges there are
different approaches you could take and
i get asked about foreign policy
periodically and when i was running for
president it was seen as something that
you know i like i needed to shore up
because obviously i hadn't uh
um served
in the military and so there was no
reason
uh to prize my foreign policy
you're right expertise
you know what one of the things i would
suggest is that i feel like
so much of our thinking has been
institutionalized where if you ask the
vast majority of americans like hey you
know if we spend way too much on these
foreign theaters including afghanistan
cost all this blood and treasure you
know for what most everyone be like yeah
it's been messed up there's this
military-industrial complex that has run
amok uh and i do believe that it's going
to try and lead us to war with china one
of the things i heard from someone who's
inside the bowels of one of these major
military suppliers was after
the cold war ended people actually said
okay like what's the next war going to
be because we need another war and so
they just start tearing and steering us
towards it because that's where the
hundreds of billions or trillions get
made
the
america we throw around the term
military-industrial complex chelsea
gabba ran on a lot but it really is just
economic incentives to stay at war right
and jobs and livelihoods and
which in a way is
the emblem for what it is that i think
we're trying to fight when i say we i
mean certainly me and you and forward
but what are the incentives really
should be the most important question in
american life now and
one of the messages i have is that if
everyone obeys their incentives we're
[ __ ] um and that means politically
it
and that what we're talking about now in
terms of foreign policy is similar it's
like well what's in my best interest if
i'm one of these mega corps it's like
let's uh
let's go pick a fight and then the rest
of us will be looking up being like well
that doesn't seem right
look
in many ways
it's trying to break this
institutionalization that is
the primary mission for america right
now if you could get in there and this
is very very difficult i mean we're
trying to do with the political
industrial complex you get in there be
like hey
the two parties spent 2.65 billion
dollars just trying to defeat each other
in congressional races most of that
canceled each other out all it did was
inflame us and piss us off at each other
right uh you know you have to get in
there and be like no this isn't right
it's like hey we spent three trillion in
afghanistan for one well you know like
like if you just to take any normal
person with common sense they'd go in
and say what are we doing but there are
these incredibly powerful forces that
are going to try and drive you in
particular directions right
um
and it's a lot of what the forward party
is i think a lot of people
the misnomer at least
or like the kind of false narrator in my
opinion on from social media i've seen
is that
the forward part is a centrist party
you're like driving down the middle and
there's some truth to that like not left
or right forward like i'm trying to ever
be rational right
but a lot of it is very very major
change progressive
like rank choice voting and open
primaries where you're actually like
fixing and ripping apart the plumbing
like we are talking you are talking
about major change this isn't like a hey
like
just so you don't have to hold your nose
we have a moderate party you know what
i'm saying like i do know what you're
saying it's so interesting like it's not
the moderate party i mean it does it's
gonna attract a lot of moderates but
it's still talking about fundamental
reform
yeah it's funny where you have to
identify what structures you're trying
to disrupt or
uh advance
and when you talk about trying to
disrupt the duopoly then you wind up in
this centrist zone even if your vision
may be pretty dramatic right you know
like one of the things i say in my book
is like we should have universal
healthcare yeah now you know that that
might not seem very moderate or
incremental it's just but to me it's
common sense and you know if you
disagree with that hey you know it's
cool yeah we can disagree
uh you know for universal basic income
which struck people as very dramatic not
that long ago even though now two thirds
of americans of every alignment are for
it
uh so that it's it's interesting
i think that the the reason why i'm kind
of cool with the entire like centrist
moderate
label is that at this point all of
politics is tribal
and what we're trying to do is attract a
particular tribe that responds to a
particular political language and that
language is
facts figures reason solutions optimism
possibility entrepreneurship
positivity
like that that language i think can
ignite
and i i have this joke um when i do my
book talks about it it's like what
percentage of americans respond to the
language of facts and then people think
about it
uh and then i i tell them it's like look
it's not 51
you know what i mean
sorry like i mean if you had the actual
number
i throw out there and i'm being a bit
conservative but i'm saying let's call
it 10 to 20
yeah but if you got 10 to 20 of
americans on board with the forward
party and this movement we win because
with that percentage you can transform
politics with that percentage you can
actually win let's call it two senate
seats how many senate seats do you need
to control the agenda one apparently
apparently one that's right
and it could be realistic for us to get
that one senate seat in 2022 yeah so
when people look at it and be like oh
can't win 51 it's like well if i get 10
15
and we can win a race or two we can
actually be the fulcrum on which
everything turns or is balanced
uh so that's
one of the fun things about what we're
building
is the new tribe
can attract people for different reasons
and it's been a funny adjustment for me
just thinking all politics are tribal
and the language of facts will attract
certain people
joe manchin seems to be the center from
west virginia seems to be the most
powerful
person in the world right now at least
from a come from a media agenda setting
standpoint
he
is
a moderate i think we're fair and he's
like kind of like run on he's like i'm
not
you know a con a hyper conservative i'm
not a pro-trump hardcore republican but
so i'm a democrat but sometimes a
democrat name only just to kind of
win over some independence and um but
my question for you is is kind of
transitioning to what's happened in the
news right now where i feel like
one man from west virginia
who lives in west virginia which is a
very different place than most of the
country
ignoring political views it's just his
own place i've been to west virginia
it's wonderful it's beautiful but it's
different
um
that man's political views are going to
shape at least they're shaping our
policy agenda right now
um is the dream of the forward party to
get more joe mansions in there that are
maybe
um a little more open-minded what what's
the um the concept there and then maybe
how's it in your eyes playing out in the
um
current biden
agenda
goals through congress
so let's talk about what's going on with
the democrats and the two major bills
now there was all of this
pressure
to try and deliver the bills at the end
of september because that was the
express timeline and people were
promised to vote
and then that evaporated they said okay
we're going to do it now by the end of
october
i am concerned
that it's going to be difficult to
create that urgency again
uh because you know you have all these
late nights and everyone's building
towards and then you send everyone home
then everyone can kind of get more
entrenched and go and
then it seems like it is possible that
it falls apart because it's it's falling
apart once
now
on the other side of the ledger it is
legitimately political malpractice and
suicide for the democrats not to pass
both the infrastructure bill and some
version the reconciliation right it like
this is literally their their loan shot
at it and they need to get it done
essentially regardless of the political
consequences for them because one of the
strange things that's going on right now
is it's not clear that they're going to
get a proper level of political credit
uh i just saw a graphic where something
like 28 percent of americans think that
this mega bill is going to help them
which is by the way inaccurate it would
touch more
yeah like child tax credit alone is
um you know in excess of that number um
i think
so
the fact that joe manchin controls the
agenda like i talked to someone who's
close to the process and the fact is
democrats are just kind of glad they
have a democrat in west virginia so that
you know they look at it where like joe
manchin is kind of extra
you know what i mean it's like west
virginia by wright's a very red state i
think it was like trump plus 16 or
something like that right so the fact
that they have a walking talking
democrat in west virginia they don't
know about it they're just like whatever
joe like we'll we'll work with it yes um
in some ways the more interesting figure
is kirsten cinema even though arizona is
purple uh kirsten cinema came from the
left
and
um she's
i think
viewed as in some ways uh someone who
would be more likely to be on board with
this agenda than joe banshen originally
[Music]
[Music]
some people are into wine some people
are into chocolate and some people
listening to this right now are into
coffee and so if you can imagine
getting one of up to 400 plus craft
coffees delivered to your door with
place of origin feel like you're
traveling the world then trade is for
you
and for people listening right now trade
is offering your first bag free
and five dollars off your bundle
go to drinktrade.comyang
and use promo code yang take the quiz to
start your journey to the perfect cup
wow this sounds freaking incredible
that's drinktrade.com
yang promo code yang for your first bag
free
and five dollars off your first bundle
so joe joe in particular
i'm curious your thoughts on this
he had just come out saying um
the child tax credit which is doing
right now it needs to be means tested
and it brought up an old argument that
we had talked about a lot on when you're
running for president where a lot of
people said your freedom dividend should
be means tested what i mean by means
tested for those who don't particularly
know these it's testing based on your
means or quote-unquote income so instead
of giving a thousand dollars a month if
we're talking about universal-based
income and stock instead of giving that
to everybody you give it to everybody
who's
over a certain income level if you make
more than 35 000 a year whatever the
number is you don't get it you've come
out against that many times like in this
particular case why is it bad or in
general why do you disagree with it
i generally dislike means testing
because i think that the
administration's a pain it causes people
to play games and and misreport uh it
stigmatizes things
uh giving people some stuff that they
don't need
you know to me is not that big a problem
right um in the context of the child tax
credit i understand why someone would
run a means test it yeah work
requirements too yeah so it's both
incoming and work yeah yeah the work
requirement is a whole nother ball of
wax right uh like i i would understand
different limits on income for the child
tax credit because there are some
wealthy families who you know it's like
the child tax credit doesn't really
affect them or touch them right uh and
in some ways
identifying families that need the child
tax credit is something that is a little
bit easier because
in in this instance
most of these families do have tax
returns in the rest of it and their
situation theoretically i guess is
somewhat stable over time
i'd still prefer not to be mean tested
but i don't hate the means testing as
much uh if we're talking specifically
about the child tax credit
yeah and
if it
causes the child tax credit to be
uh persistent or even uh perpetual
then i i'd you know again at this point
like anything we can do to help on that
side i'm for
uh
it is wild though how much influence
that that joe has
uh and i i'm
i will say that i've gotten some word
that people are optimistic that the
child tax credit will at least be
included in the reconciliation bill on
in some form
so
the conservative argument i always heard
about means testing or worker crimes
things like this is is something
actually very visceral or like it's
instinctive to a lot of humans it's like
well you're just going gonna give it
away for free who's paying for that
right um
and you make an argument which i agree
with especially when you look at numbers
that
that makes sense on the face of it we're
like yeah we shouldn't just like blindly
be giving away things but
the cost associated with enforcing that
and the nominal amount of people who are
faking it or abusing the system it's
usually more expensive to enforce it
and for what right like for a very small
margin um
and i'm that still plays out with the
child tax credit i think too right there
will be sure there will be some who are
i don't know having babies for more
incoming whatever your
yeah that's why
yeah the dark story i mean it's my mom
worked at a um halfway house she has
seen like
um
let's call it the cycle of poverty where
people are literally just living on
government checks and never have
intention of getting a job but i would
say that's the exception not the rule
and usually part of a darker system than
um
the kind of the conservative argument of
rewarding bad behavior um but thought
like you know
this in this case it would um you'd
probably be more expensive to enforce it
no
no you know in this case enforcing it
would not be very expensive because all
they're going to do is draw an income
threshold or for a child tax credit yeah
the child high school they're just going
to say like look you make above a
certain amount you don't get it or it
scales down just based on your tax
returns right yeah okay
um
do you
i guess probably
do you think are we in a situation right
now or whatever joe manchin says the by
administration is going to just bend
over backwards to appeal to is it him
and kristen that are are you going to
like are we just following their lead on
our legislation now or is there room for
compromise in your opinion joe joe
manchin and kirsten sent him uh they're
running the agenda
whatever whatever they say they'll allow
in
uh is going to happen because at this
point the vast like literally it's like
98 of the other democrats are like let's
do some version of this
here are the different provisions so
there are a bunch of variables a bunch
of balls in the air about things that
may or may not be in
the the final version
uh it's kind of wild really like all the
unknowns because they had this list of
things that they wanted to get in the
headline cost is three and a half
trillion now it looks like the final
bill is going to be a little more than
half that size people are talking about
2 trillion so then where do you
get the 1.5 trillion dollars in savings
one of the major question marks for a
lot of them was are we going to take the
same amount of programs and just shorten
the time because one thing we don't talk
about enough is that even the 3.5
trillion was over 10 years you're
looking at 350 billion a year it's a
it's like something like a 9 increase in
federal spending it's a lot but it's not
three and a half trillion a year it's
like you know and so then if you shrink
it to two trillion let's say you could
do the exact same things as you wanted
to do originally over five and a half
years instead of ten or something like
that so that was one model and then the
other model is like let's fully pay for
it and stretch it around the 10. is
there any logic to
getting this stuff getting it through
the getting it through congress and then
working out the details later right
where you know you pass a bill it's five
years but then we try to extend it to
ten and one into less toxic well that's
one of the arguments too is like after
you do it they can't undo it so that's
one of the
rationales behind just trying to shorten
the time frame right
uh on the other hand is that they could
undo it
especially if the republicans win
congress next fall which betting markets
have that as a 72 percent likelihood
that high yes uh two long-standing
democrats just said they would not run
for re-election which i have to say and
i met one of the mike doyle he's a
really good dude he's in pennsylvania
he's not running he's not running again
and and so if you have folks like that
not running again
they're looking up and saying one they
might not win their races because mike
was in a competitive part of pa but two
also they they don't think they're going
to be in the majority and and so that
sucks yeah so that sucks too so there
are data points that are making it quite
pessimistic that democrats will retain
the majority of the house in 2022.
one of the reasons i love the forward
parties because i'm not on the
presidential i got to know
not well but i got i sat on a couple
planes next to senators or picked their
brain and people you know people you
wouldn't normally expect to spend time
i've got to spend time with
and a lot of i'll they were confidential
conversations but um
a lot of them are running for president
because there was nothing to do
as a senator because either if they
weren't majority there was literally
nothing to do and if they were in the
majority they didn't get a bill until
hours before the vote happened um
and that's a problem guys
um
one of the places we saw this recently
was freaking the the crypto provisions
in the infrastructure package oh yeah
where they were doing the infrastructure
package then someone was like hey you
know what we're going to do we're going
to throw some language crypto and we're
going to define broker dealers this way
and then the cryptocurrency industry
like them was like wait what you're
doing what what and it was so last
minute there was not much consultation
people came in and said look like let's
amend this line it should be more
reasonable and then one senator killed
that
uh and so i think if people understood
just how
hurt this legislative process is you'd
be saddened but you know legislators
complained to me oh no no me to everyone
just say look you're giving me a
thousand page bill and you're giving me
36 hours to review it the whole thing's
like ridiculous um and sometimes the
people that are making those complaints
are in the same party it's it's not even
that there's the minority party which is
like well i guess i'm gonna vote against
this thing
it's like you're at the same party and
it's like what the heck am i gonna do
and then they were like fall in line
do it vote for it
i was a
friend of mine works on capitol hill and
she told me her job like the vast she
works for a senator i'll leave nameless
for now but a democrat
and one of the things she said was that
a big part of her job is making sure the
senator
is present to actually vote
because when the votes happen you never
know what's going on it's last minute
like we're voting in 20 minutes or
voting in an hour or whatever it is and
literally they miss
you miss votes and you don't know what
you're voting on you just have to line
up and actually vote because that's you
know literally the job um so they have a
full-time person just to make sure they
physically
are present to vote um
which to me feels like a bit of a waste
of resources in the sense that they're
all pretty talented um
enough to you know maybe if they had a
little lead time to like manage their
own schedule on that but
anyway
here we are brother yes
[Music]
[Music]
we're spending a lot more time at home
nowadays and one way to make that time
more fruitful is skillshare you can
learn design you can take a course on
self-care with jonathan van ness you can
learn how to be a more successful
youtuber
or maybe become a youtuber if you're not
one already
so if this sounds like something you'd
be excited about skillshare is for you
there are so many different classes a
friend of mine is actually the
co-founder of skillshare it's one reason
why i swear by it explore your
creativity at skillshare.com yang and
get a one month free trial
premium membership that's one month off
a premium membership at
skillshare.com yang subscribe today and
watch your skills grow i made up that
tagline what do you think think
skillshare is going to take it
i i did get some attention for
advocating for term limits uh
this best week yeah um and and i i just
think a little bit and i do think right
now that this is an issue and you know
what's funny is people are pushing back
and be like oh you understand it's like
what i don't think people realize that
one three-quarters of americans are for
this and there was tremendous momentum
around this in the 90s so much so that a
half a dozen states actually passed term
limits for their own representatives in
94 where they were like hey let let's do
this yeah and then majority of house
members in 1995 said voted on term
limits to pass them
so not that long ago everyone was like
oh this is the right move and then the
supreme court voted 5'4 saying no you
can't vote term limits for your own
representatives which is a very very
strange ruling i'm going to suggest
because there's no rule about any of
this anywhere and so if a state wanted
to circumscribe the duration of their
representative stint in congress it
seems to me like they should be able to
do it whenever i was
running for president and mentioned this
everyone just freaking applaud like
everyone wanted term limits out there in
the world
uh and the counter arguments against it
who's pushing back what are these
counter arguments please
the count arguments uh are institutional
knowledge it's institutional knowledge
which again like so i'm proposing term
limits of 18 years per house
um that because so there's a legitimate
argument against term limits and here it
is is that if let's say i had term
limits of six years or eight years which
they do in california
people show up and they're not even able
to organize into coalitions they don't
really know what's going on and then the
lobbyists just freaking run rings around
them just like you guys don't don't know
what the institutions go around the
elected officials right it's a
consultant to stick around and leech or
whatever yes yeah and and there's so
much churn
that you can't actually build like the
the proper degree of and people probably
just run in for their next office too if
you if you have to be out in a certain
amount of time
yeah it's a little bit too short term
yeah so that so there's a very
legitimate counter argument to this it's
one reason why i'm proposing 18 years
per house because that's six house terms
three senate terms enough time for you
to actually build a degree yep of
organization uh and hierarchy
and also if you served in both houses
you could have a very full 36-year
career
so that strikes me as like the right
balance
um so there the legitimate counter
argument is like look you can't make it
too short and i was like yeah okay i get
i get it
um 18 years is a pretty long time and
when people the other thing they talk
about is like the learning curve and i'm
just like
what learning curve takes more than 18
years you know what i mean you know
it's like oh by year 28 like that's when
i really started to understand you know
like and and right now there is a very
very strange
seniority-based hierarchy going on in
the u.s congress
and ro khanna said you have people who
won election in the 80s and 90s running
the place who then
cater to people who won 15 years ago
and
as a result
nancy pelosi 81 years old steny hoyer
also 81 i believe chuck schumer is a
relatively spry 70.
mitch mcconnell 79 the the folks who are
in charge of these places have been
there forever
and the deficiencies in my mind are
uh one you're just behind the curve all
the time
you know i mean like you know if you go
to them about social media they don't
understand at all because you know they
might never have checked email you know
like they think about your 80 year old
relatives like my dad's 83. uh you know
like how much does he understand about
these platforms very very little
uh and those those are the people who
are running the show
um so that's one problem yeah the the
other problem is that
i do think you get more
institutionalized longer in dc
uh and
if you're there for 10 12 years
it's still going to be pretty extreme
but if you're there for like 20 25 30
years
it's also not great even for
just the the the fact that health will
start becoming an issue for some of
these legislators you have chuck
grassley who's 88 who's running again
you have uh
dianne feinstein who's 88 and there have
been reports about her
losing her her faculties
you know which
i mean that's not a knock on her it's
like what 88 year old
like is you know i mean like that that's
or or and this isn't directly about term
limits but it's i it actually i'm going
to suggest does have a relationship um
that the
two presidential candidates may have a
combined age of 158
in uh 2024.
you know and that there's like a product
of this seniority system that really is
in my mind detrimental uh to a system
that rejuvenates itself or refreshes its
own leadership
um so i i think term limits make sense
uh and most americans agree and then
there's like a very very strange tribe
of people over like no
you know like you and and i'm just like
what is
what what is the problem and i even have
a way that's like look if you love some
of the people who are currently in
office okay i get it you're very
attached it's cool uh what i'm
suggesting is you vote in term limits
and say it doesn't apply to current
legislators because that way they don't
have to kick themselves out right
because it's too much to ask for them to
say hey like i'm immediately going to
retire after i pass this bill so you can
have essentially like a grandfathered in
class of legislators will just be
knocking around the place for as long as
they can win and then everyone who comes
in after them is subject to these
18-year limits but eventually this group
would phase out and then you'd have like
a genuinely dynamic self-restoring
culture which ideally by the way would
not consist of people who are only in
two parties ideally you'd have people
who were in multiple parties
uh being able to build different
coalitions that again would refresh
themselves if the ford party has its way
they'll be open primaries and ranked
choice voting and then you might see
some new perspectives emerge
do you think it's hard for people
to go from politics back into the real
world oh yeah for sure
you know like you know like
an incentive to
this is something that i'm so glad you
raised as zach because one of the things
i think we should be doing we should be
just throwing cash at legislators to
leave their [ __ ] jobs
you know what i mean
because right now it's like their job is
like much better than anything else they
could do and then lobby being a lobbyist
is the best thing they could ever do
it's like we should just be like hey as
soon as you're in congress you should be
like throwing cash at you to stop being
a legislator
anytime you stop i like it's probably an
roi i guess the point is like if you're
a senator
or you're a former governor christie i
mean he had some you know some i guess a
little bit of a scandal but governor
chris christie after that
what do you do let's say you're not
disgraced to say you're just you just
missed a dude
or you lost i guess well what do you do
if you look at what most former
politicians do they become some version
of lobbyist connection maker influence
peddler often are private attorneys
right like i guess often associated with
the law firm or with a financial
services firm in some cases because a
lot of these law firms and financial
services firms do just traffic in
relationships so if you get someone
who's really really plugged in and they
can make phone calls to a very very
senior person that might be worth a six
figure salary to you just to have that
person around yep maybe they bring in
some business maybe they they rain me
maybe they you trot them out for clients
and they're just excited to talk to
someone who you know has been in that
kind of position every fortune 100
i don't know if it's every but it's a
vast majority it's probably the bastard
of the fortune 500 every public company
usually has some form of public policy
office and they pay someone
decently handsomely six-figure salary um
some ubs had a whole team of folks that
just
traffic in dc you know call up
relationships um so that makes sense but
those jobs
if you're a legislator or someone who's
been like when you're a candidate you're
star of the show it's you know your
name's on the ballot it's months and
months and years and years of your name
and your fundraisers and your luncheons
and your donations and your fans all
this stuff and then to tell people to
turn that off
and probably go to income zero or be
like behind the scenes it's a like they
take the human side and some people are
like oh who cares you're just a
politician but there's a human side of
it that why would
leaving sucks leaving is not better than
sitting around doing nothing collecting
a paycheck in dc and having all the
accolades i was just talking about yeah
you're the center of a lot of attention
you go in a room and people like really
want to get in front of you and the rest
of it and giving that up is very
difficult for you you made it all your
elements all your teachers are proud of
you you know i like you yeah you know
something you know what i'd compare it
to and this is something i'll speak to
personally you know because yeah
i'd compare it to
being a performer in a creative field uh
or being a professional athlete um
so let's say you're a professional
athlete and then you're like hey your
career's over like go back and then what
like for that athlete they're like oh
nothing's as
as
visceral and competitive and real and
engaging as being on the field and so
you know maybe i get into coaching maybe
i get in the media maybe i get into
business and i fart around like that
transition is very very difficult brutal
our boy jj redick just retired for a
professional athlete yeah we gotta have
jj in we should have jj you know he's a
good person he'll be but like he's like
talented on camera enough and has done
some things outside of basketball you
know the average
yeah
jj is exceptional
um like i i was the entrepreneurship
mentor
and entrepreneurship mentor for the nba
players association for uh several years
right i met dozens of former players and
most of them really really deeply
struggle with the transition yes uh and
there are a number of reasons they've
been laser focused on one thing they
can't do that thing anymore everyone
thinks that they're made of money when
often they are not they have dozens of
people that rely upon them they also
aren't very good at evincing either
ignorance uh or doubt so if someone
comes to them and it's like hey here's
this thing and they don't understand it
then they don't uh admit they don't
understand it the job is not to fail
their whole life right yeah people are
always trying to take advantage of them
so
it's a very very tough thing for if
you're a performer then you feel like
you're you know not cool anymore it has
been it's like let's say you were a
musician you were in front of a bunch of
people and then that now you know no one
uh listens to your stuff anymore or or
you're not or you're an actor and you're
in some duds and then no one wants to
catch you're the actor that everybody
knows the role you're in but you're
never got anything else you know for a
number of reasons you were in glee as a
tertiary character whatever it is uh so
that's what i think being a politician
is like for a lot of folks it's like
you're at the center of the vortex and
then you leave and then it's like oh
and you want to stay in that pocket even
though there are some elements of it
that are you know not fun but it's still
a hundred times more exciting
and relevant than the other things that
you would do
[Music]
welcome to fallen angel a documentary
podcast about victoria's secret and its
many many secrets
our new series investigates the origin
story and meteoric rise of one of the
world's most iconic brands the legendary
business mogul who created the
inescapable fantasy and the reckoning
that victoria's secret faces today all
told by women who strut strutted the
runways and witnessed what happened
behind the curtain i was so hungry and
my body wasn't working he said that
women only work out to look good naked
to have sex with men like just gross a
direction and production of c13
originals a cadence 13 studio and
campsite media and hosted by vanessa
gregoriotis and me justine harmon
fallen angel is available to listen to
for free wherever you listen to your
podcasts like you might have made a deal
with the devil
and they called it angels because now
you are locked in
[Music]
and so i'm going to speak personally
about you know my own experience in this
light because of the folks who've
supported me and thank you again for
this like i feel like i'm now someone
who might be able to make a difference
in american life and so i'm going to try
and use that to spotlight the fact that
our system right now is designed to pit
us against each other and frustrate us
and
elevate the
polarization and we need to try and
change the wiring of the system
now i'm a fairly
i think you know i'm like a fairly
normal well-adjusted person uh you know
that
excerpt from my book that was in
politico was talking about how you know
power causes brain damage and whatnot
like you've been around me and i think
you know to the extent that someone can
get through that process without a real
personality like transformation into
like you know uh like someone that
everyone hates
you
i'm a different human from the so we're
definitely different humans um but the
the tough thing is that at root and you
know this about me is that before i ran
for office i was an operator i like
machine you know i like building orgs i
like doing things problems yeah solving
problems and then now
uh like our operation actually consists
of me
putting ideas out speaking
uh doing
media talking you know being trying to
build a movement trying to build a new
political party which by the way is like
an extraordinarily you know like tough
challenge i mean people look at it and
like i'm i'm well aware of the fact that
other people have tried to do it and has
not gone well and like i believe that
we're going to break through and the
early returns are very positive
um but
yeah you know i understand it and one of
the things that blows my mind is that
i'm in a position and again i'm grateful
to everyone who supported me where i
enjoy most of the fruits of successful
political runs despite not having uh
actually won where like the you know
what i mean like i do
you have fans most people don't get fans
until after elected aoc for example
she like who she is she was not that
before she won
she won in a district and
she was incredible that she won but she
became aoc
after she won right um anyway so i
interrupted you no no it's fine so i i
try to appreciate what it is other
people go through i mean politics is
rough and
politics does destroy people like it
destroys you know their families their
relationships you know people come and
they burn out in various ways you and i
know like
a dozen people who burnt out which i i
totally appreciate yeah and may they you
know recover
that's the presidential politics too
that's a crucible in its own way
um so that so this is you know i so i do
think term limits it would be important
in part because uh people are not going
to want to leave the stage and you know
unless they're kicking and screaming and
so if you build something in and i do
think we should be just
giving them massive like off-ramps uh to
be like hey great job you're a member of
congress you're now not anymore here's
like a freaking giant stipend there's a
two-year salary for yourselves right so
that but you'd have to say that on the
front end so you could attract more
talent well what i said on the front end
is like i said that you can go to any
non-profit or academic institution and
bring with you a stipend of a hundred
thousand dollars a year on top of
whatever they'll pay you right for a
decade it's essentially like a million
dollar
kind of um like off-ramp
um and i i thought that would be a
pretty good deal because you could go
anywhere and just bring your own money
with you and then everyone would hire
you and they'd probably pay you on top
this is interesting don't don't get me
wrong they'd probably pay you on top
cause hundred grand is like you know not
not like
you know you live a lot of these folks
are not used to just making that much
money right yeah they'd want to make
more but they they could um that that's
a that's not a terrible idea right it's
not about i like incentives for more
people run for office i like getting
you'd have to fix up you know doing
these things in a vacuum not great like
i think a lot like you know
you've seen the stats on people's net
worth before they get to congress and
then how do they become so rich the
whole thing is so weird yeah it's like
they show up normal uh you know this is
another thing too someone asked me it's
like do you think that members of
congress should be restricted from
owning stock and i do it's just too easy
a way to be corrupt
um now again i have nothing against
people making money like i'd be totally
cool with you just being like look we're
gonna pay you more we're gonna give you
giant bonuses when you leave like i
don't want you to think about money that
stuff is fine
um but saying like hey you can own stock
and by the way you're in a position
where everyone's going to want to try
and make you happy so they can get some
special treatment like that's a pretty
dumb it's a conflict of interest [ __ ]
yeah um it's imagine it's um
they're dealing with
when you're a politician you are raising
money from some of the wealthiest people
in the world well people who can write a
twenty hundred dollar check or five
dollar check wherever it is and they a
lot of companies a lot of them run
companies private companies are like hey
you know want to invest in this get an
early ground floor and they love putting
here they love putting you on a board of
advisors or
you are a legitimizer automatically
that's how i think this works i mean
some of you the some of it's probably
the kelly leffler uh
like sexually corrupt [ __ ] um
a lot of it's that gray area yeah it's
just like hey i've got this great deal
like the clinton white water thing that
sort of thing yeah whereas i oh you know
it would be great like i've got this
company i think it's gonna go great
it'll be great if it you as our advisor
we'll give you some shares in this
company and you know you let us use your
name behind the scenes just say as
you're you're blessing our legitimacy
and then it works out for them
that's not great
um i think it's like the dark money
there's a lot of this kind of soft
corruption yeah really it's the
incentive thing where it's the incentive
thing all over the incentives are
they're all destroying everybody's just
trying to
like get like you know there's plenty of
people have good intentions but the
other day they're just trying to take
care of their kids frankly
yeah and it's one of the quotes from
ezra that i used in my book ezra klein
yeah where it talks about how toxic
systems compromise good individuals with
ease yeah that that really is the issue
and if you wanted to be serious about
having different outcomes you'd have
very different incentives and you would
invest more
in both rewarding people
trying to align their incentives and and
try and clean it up yeah
um
i guess i'll shift gears a little a bit
as we wrap this up you had said
something um it may be a good thing to
end on you had talked about the lack of
folks
apologizing
all right so i had this exchange with
someone and they they talked about uh
mistakes made and like uh politicians
accepting blame and then what i said to
them was like look at this point in
american life if you accept blame for
anything all it's going to do is fuel
negative news cycles and so when the
afghanistan which all happened and then
joe biden was put in that position he
had to essentially be like everything
was perfect everyone agreed we're all on
board the plan was perfect uh and
executed um and you know people can be
mad at him for that but if he had said
yeah like you know there was
disagreement the general disagreed which
by the way came out later the generals
apparently said like hey we weren't on
board with this um all it's going to do
is fuel very very negative news coverage
so you have a system of incentives now
where no one can admit fault because
they admit fault they're just going to
get
pelted for an extra day or two whereas
if they just stonewall and say it was
perfect we did it and if that sounds
familiar to you i mean it sounds a
little bit trumpian but like but that's
where the incentives are going where
you don't want to admit faults and it's
going to make unfortunately our leaders
seem less and less
humble and human over time i feel like
we can do a whole episode on this but
what you're talking about is
authenticity and there's a difference
between authenticity of institutions and
individuals and the institutions in
general it's harder for them to be
authentic because if you're the cdc you
can't be like hey the vaccine's like
okay or vaccine's really awesome but
it's not perfect you got to be like take
vaccine it's awesome right that's their
job that's true um there becomes a party
line yeah and if you're and the problem
is if you're um
if you're human and you mess up your
individual you do something you're
confident you messed up
you'll get a lot of negative press on
the mess up but you're gonna get a lot
more press or just as much press at
times for the apology on the mess up so
then you end up in this
weird spot and the key i think is to
just be authentic the whole time which i
think you're generally pretty good at
but we've had our mistakes and times
where you like
oh yeah that wasn't great or whatever it
may be well i'll tell you i've been in
that position now and like the media
incentives truly are just to be like uh
it was great it was great it went great
it was great because if you say it
wasn't great all you're going to do is
get like a whole new speed of stories
being like
you know they said it wasn't great
and and then it you know you so
that that's it's going to distort things
for for everyone and so i closed that
conversation with
um the the person the questioner i said
that's why we never admit fault you know
like so it was good for a laugh but it's
unfortunately somewhat accurate the
media wants the apology all the time
even if you um don't have anything to
apologize for but there's time in that
situation you feel like an [ __ ] for
not apologizing because you know there's
things going wrong or whatever it is
yeah then everyone around you will
advise you be like look don't apologize
all it does is be one more news cycle
we're just trying to make this new cycle
end oh we could do a whole episode of
this maybe we will anyway um i'm wearing
my buffalo bills right now because we're
recording this on monday night football
but on thursday
if the bills lose tonight which not
we're winning tonight but if we did lose
be nice ford tour continuing thank you
all for the support much love i will see
you on the road
[Music]
you